Hello, the internet.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
And I feel like for this one, Dan,
we should just crack on.
Everyone knows we're going
to smash this mirror.
Was that a joke?
Crack?
Crack on?
It wasn't.
Oh, well, good work anyway.
Well, thank you very much.
Gonna get a hammer, smash
the mirror to pieces.
Let's go.
Are you aware of the seven years bad luck?
I'm currently on 23 years,
at the minute, bad luck, so.
All right, that's not a multiple of seven.
So I guess, you've gotten some down?
Yeah.
Okay, okay good.
Glass breaks rapidly,
so it won't be a high res one.
We're going to shoot low,
at 120,000 frames a second.
Pressure's on, pressure's on.
You've only got one mirror.
Think we'll get it?
Yeah, why not?
I'm going to frame it so that you can see
the reflection of this one in the mirror.
I like it.
So, it's like
you're throwing it straight at the lens.
I've never missed, so.
Well, actually, it'd be
like you throwing a hammer
at a hammer that destroys itself.
I reckon it'll look cool.
You ready?
Yeah.
Flippin' heck, the hammer
went right through.
Cool.
All right, so I'm playing
this back sped up.
This is the equivalent of
if we were shooting this
at 2,500 frames a second, which
is what we usually shoot at.
So, this would be-
So, a normal camera.
Yeah, this will be way too fast.
Oh, instant.
Brilliant.
And that tells us nothing.
Yeah, one frame.
That is so fast.
Yeah, we definitely need
to slow that down a lot.
So, this is at 120,000 frames a second.
Is it stopped, or what?
It barely looks like it's moving.
Okay, oh!
Oh God!
Did you see that shockwave?
Yeah, hold on, let me do it
frame-by-frame, hold on.
Oh!
It's like that shot in the matrix
where the helicopter hits the building.
It's exactly like that.
And the thing is, I was
watching that at the time.
I was like, yeah, there's
no way that happens.
Did they know? Or did they just guess?
They can't have known.
How would they have known?
So, there's a shockwave
that moves through the glass
before the glass cracks
and the glass cracks into the shockwave.
It collapses into the bowl.
That's awesome.
They were right, with the helicopter.
All right, let's speed it up again.
Oh, that lens flare. That's amazing.
So, we've recreated it with a hammer,
what they did with the
helicopter into a building.
Now I want to try
with a much bigger pane of glass.
Let's try and get some
more lens flares in.
Look, look!
Ah, that is stunning.
There's a bit rainbow there, as well.
Nice.
I like, for some select moments,
the sun is reflecting
off a piece of mirror
that's half hanging in the air.
Like straight into the lens's face.
So, I hit the middle of the glass, right?
Yeah.
The hammer went
all the way to the back here,
hit that, and bounced off.
I just realized, you almost
smashed another video.
I know.
There's a pane of glass there.
If you fell through that, you
would be absolutely murdered.
You would, wouldn't you?
Look at it, really, it's so sharp!
It's only little shards.
That's real glass, that is.
That's savage.
One of those plastic Wal-Mart mirrors.
Target ones.
Good aim.
Thank you!
You're really good at like, bizarre stuff.
You can put an ax head at wherever.
I've got a very specific set of skills
and they're all useless.
You can throw a lopsided weight
directly into one spot.
Yes.
That was cool.
Yeah, it was.
The frame rate was definitely needed.
Hopefully one day,
cameras that can do
120,000 frames a second
also do it in like 4K.
That'd be amazing.
That would be the dream.
We'll probably be 58 by then.
Well, then, at that point
I'll have run out of bad luck.
So, I'll have to redo this again.
God, it's bright.
Keep nailing my eyes.
I keep trying, that's why.
So, what're you at?
You're at now 30 years bad luck?
That's older than me!
So, you've got more bad luck to come
than you've actually lived yet.
So, I will be 58 by the time-
Really?
Yeah!
You just guessed that, or did you realize?
I just guessed it.
I just threw out a random number.
That's literally the age I'll be.
I was like, ah yeah.
So, by the time your luck's run out,
we'll be able to film it again in 4K
and I'll have another
seven years bad luck.
All right.
Brilliant.
We're just gonna wait for
technology at this point.
Okay, well hopefully
you enjoyed that video.
Pretty brief one.
You can follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe to the second channel.
God.
See if you can nail the lens.
Oh, you blinded 'em.
Yep.
They're completely blind now.
I feel like I'm in school
with my watch again,
trying to get the teacher in the eyes.
Who did you get in the eye at school?
Mr. Lear.
I got Mr. War.
I called him George, once.
He gave me a Friday detention.
I was just like, "George".
And he went, "Friday".
Can't first name a teacher
in secondary school.
Just not on.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
We'll see you in the next one, hopefully.
And if you wait around 30 or so years,
we'll be back doing this one again.
More bad luck.